[Music]  full speed ahead for ariana grande and  her fiance SNL star Pete Davidson up  first in tonight's know and tell Ariana  and Pete luxury digs  that's the newly engaged couple in New  York leaving through a side door at  Bobby Flay's got the restaurant  that's Bobby photobombing the shot a  source confirms the et that Ariana and  Pete are now in fact living together and  are excited for the next chapter that  next chapter includes an eye-popping 16  million dollar apartment on Manhattan's  West Side they just bought over four  thousand square feet with 5 bedrooms and  four and a half baths it includes a  private balcony with a killer view of  New York skyline not bad for two 24 year  olds  [Music]